you've learned how to implement
exponentially weighted averages there's
one technical detail called bias
correction that can make your
computation of these averages more
accurately let's see how that works
in the previous video you saw this
figure for beta equals 0.9 this figure
for beta equals 0.98 but it turns out
that if you implement the formula as
written here you won't actually get the
green curve when say beta equals 0.98
you actually get the purple curve here
and you notice that the purple curve
starts off really low so let's see how
to fix that when you're implementing a
moving average you initialize it with B
zero equals zero and then V 1 is equal
to 0.98 V zero plus 0.02 theta one but
the zero is equal to 0 so that term just
goes away so B 1 is just 0.02 times
theta 1 so that's why if the first day's
temperature is say 40 degrees Fahrenheit
then V 1 will be 0.02 times 40 which is
8 so you get a much lower value down
here so it's not a very good estimate of
the first day's temperature V 2 will be
0.98 times B 1 plus 0.02 times theta 2
and if you plug in you know V 1 which is
this down here and multiply it out then
you find that B 2 is actually equal to
0.98 times zero point zero 2 times theta
1 plus 0.02 times theta 2 and that is
zero point zero one nine six theta one
plus zero point zero two theta 2 so
again you know assuming if they the 1
and theta 2 a positive numbers when you
compute this B 2 will be much less than
say they want all theta 2 so B 2 is in a
very good estimate of the first two days
temperature of the year so it turns out
that there's a way to modify the
Zestimate that makes it much better and
it makes it more accurate especially
during this initial phase of your
estimate which is that instead of taking
VT take VT divided by
one minus beta to the power of T where T
is the current data you're on so let's
take a concrete example when T is equal
to 2 1 minus Bay to the power of T is 1
minus 0.98 squared and it turns out that
this is 0.0 0.6 and so your estimate of
the Thames on day 2 becomes be 2 divided
by 0.03 9 6 and this is going to be 0.01
9 6 times theta 1 plus 0.02 Zeta 2 you
notice that these two things adds up to
the nominator Oh Penelope 9 6 and so
this becomes a weighted average of theta
1 and theta 2 and this removes this bias
so you notice that dump as T becomes
large beta to the T will become will
approach 0 which is why when T is large
enough the bias correction makes almost
no difference this is why when T is
large the Purple Line and the green line
you are pretty much overlap but during
this initial phase of learning when
you're still warming up with your
estimate when bias correction can help
you to obtain a better estimate of
temperature and as this bias correction
that helps you go from the purple line
to the green line so in machine learning
for most informations of the exponential
weighted average people don't often
bother to implement bias Corrections
because most people would rather just
wait that initial period and a slightly
more bias estimate and go from there but
we are concerned about the buyers during
this initial phase while you're
exponentially weighted moving average is
the warming up or then bias Corrections
can help you get a better estimate early
on so that you now know how to implement
exponentially weighted moving averages
let's go on and use this to build some
better optimization algorithms